reasontv presents citizens against
government waste stalkers of the month
senator sherrod Brown John Kerry and
Patrick Leahy a fine we will go applying
we will go shake General Electric didn't
win the contract to develop an engine
for the f-35 Joint Strike Fighter but
Congress decided they should build one
anyway in the name of competition by the
way GE spent thirty nine point three
million dollars on congressional
lobbying last year I'm sure that has
nothing to do with it it's probably not
important at all I don't even know why I
mentioned it despite opposition from two
presidents Donald Rumsfeld and Defense
Secretary Robert Gates who fell today
wasteful boondoggle 1.2 billion dollars
in earmarks have already gone to this
propulsion redundancy the Pentagon
doesn't even want with that funding
recently in jeopardy these three
aviation engineering experts pushed the
Pentagon to throw even more taxpayer
dollars at GE to develop this
ludicrously expensive engine that nobody
wants after spending a combined 87 years
in Congress they must know more about
what the military wants then the
military does because the only general
that wants this engine is General
Electric we ought to get contract for a
million up congratulations senators you
three are citizens against government
waste sparkers of the month for more
information about poker of the month and
other government waste issues visit CA
GW org
you